[музика]
Щиро вітаємо вас це програма У фокусі
Європи і телекомпанії Deutsche Welle вже
майже 8 місяців поспіль Росія веде війну
проти України атаки на цивільні об'єкти
не припиняються
столиці України Київ знову опинилася в
центрі обстрілів росіян про напади
мешканців постійно попереджає сигнал
повітряної тривоги після них центрі
міста зруйновані шатрові будинки є
загиблі та постраждалі
але є проблиски Надії завдяки військовим
успіхам України на сході на неокуповану
частину Донбасу знову можуть їздити
потяги зокрема до міста Краматорськ де
кілька місяців тому від російських ракет
загинуло багато українців під час
евакуації
повернення до Краматорська зворушливий
момент для Українки Олени федорової адже
тепер вона може повернутися на свою
ферму поблизу міста її супроводжував наш
кореспондент у першому потязі з Києва
потяг вчасно прибуває на станцію його
Пункт призначення місто у зоні бойових
дій уперше за півроку з Києва
відправляється потяг до Краматорська
столиці підконтрольної Україні частини
Донбасу
подорож займе сім годин якщо все буде
добре у потязі 60 пасажирів його
анонсували лише напередодні увечері з
міркувань безпеки серед пасажирів Олена
Федорова з двома дітьми Вони
повертаються назад на Батьківщину
а ми хотіли поїхати автобусом але туди
нічого не їде і коли вчора ввечері Ми
знайшли цей поїзд то я мало не
розплакалась
ми були півроку в Польщі і тепер хочемо
додому
[музика]
залізничне сполучення було призупинено у
квітні після ракетного обстрілу вокзалу
Краматорська коли загинуло понад 50
людей які намагалися втекти з міста
[музика]
під час війни залізниця стала в Україні
життєво необхідною для виживання
спочатку війни мільйони людей покинули
території за які ведуться бої на
евакуаційних потягах залізниці має
вирішальне значення також і для
забезпечення країни найнеобхіднішим для
машиніста Олександра цеганюка цей
маршрут означає більше ніж просто
залізничне сполучення
ми
час своєї часточкою
піддержем хоч моральну піддержати і
жителів Донбасу Показати що ми всі разом
що Донбас це тоже Україна
[музика]
сполучення стало можливим лише завдяки
відвойованим українською армією новим
територіям на Донбасі
принаймні зараз фронт не так близько до
залізничної колії і вона знаходиться
поза зоною досяжності артилерії
залізничні споруди в країні раз по раз
піддаються обстрілам як об'єкт критичної
інфраструктури залізниця є ціллю атак
Росії
кожен раз ми взаємодії з військовими
моніторами ситуацію але дуже важливо що
в нас багато персоналу який готовий
навіть у випадку якихось пошкоджень
інфраструктури її швидко відновлювати ми
навчилися за
4,6 тижнів відновлювати мости які вмір в
мирний ситуації відновлювали місяці
чим ближче потяг наближається до
Краматорська тим чіткіше видно сліди
війни
Олена родом із одного містечка поблизу
Краматорська які багато інших людей Вона
втекла в березні спочатку до Польщі а
потім на деякий час до української
столиці
кажуть що я все-таки нервую я стурбована
Ви ж знаєте яка там ситуація
Люди там не у безпеці
Я не знаю що на нас чекає Я б хотіла
залишитись в Києві але орендна плата
занадто висока і немає роботи
Польщі було так само тож я не знаю
насправді уряд попросив людей залишити
Донбас там досі точаться запеклі бої
інфраструктура настільки пошкоджена що
багато квартир ймовірно залишатимуться
взимку без опалення
але Олена впевнена що зможе пережити
холодну пору року Вона живе в будинку
спічним опаленням
Я навіть не знаю що відчуваю мабуть
радість але нам ще їхати додому емоції
будуть напевно лише тоді коли я буду
біля подвір'я із запізненням на 20
хвилин у Краматорськ прибуває перший за
півроку потяг і його з нетерпінням
чекають люди що тут залишилися
Олена та її діти їдуть додому на зустріч
зимі сповненій невизначеності
члени молодіжних банд зокрема цієї
люблять видавати себе за жорстких
хлопців ці кадри з музичних відео були
зняті в Іспанії де поліції Все частіше
доводиться мати справу з готовими до
насильства неповнолітніми з бандитського
середовища те що багато європейців
сприйняли брат Що случилось Штатах чи
Латинській Америці поширюється також і у
великих містах Іспанії часто ворогуючі
групи не церемоняться з вибором своєї
зброї потрапивши один раз у банду
вибиратися з нею дуже важко наш
кореспондент зустрівся з підлітками Яким
це вдалося
вони молоді готові до насильства і
озброєння у Великих іспанських містах
цілими районами заправляють банди
підлітків найчастіше
летиноамериканського походження
я змалку був на вулиці і мені це
подобалося а також наркотики я виріс у
цій атмосфері
мене притягувало те що пропонувала банда
так і приєднався Тоді йому було 19
сьогодні уже 25 і він вийшов із банди ми
називаємо його домі він не хоче щоб його
упізнали через страх перед своєю
колишньою бандою зі своїми батьками Він
переїхав із домініканської республіки і
зараз живе у Мадриді
з нами були також молоді люди які не
вміли користуватися мечети
і тоді ми їх цього навчали
кілька тижнів тому поліція провела штурм
схованки злочинного угрупування
домінікан Don't play на півночі Мадрида
вони знайшли там Мачете ножі та
вогнепальну зброю
Карлос Моралес із поліцейською
профспілки с юпі знає що тепер члени
банди мають не лише латиноамериканське
коріння до банд давно приєдналася
іспанці а також іммігранти з інших країн
і середній вік лише зменшуються
дедалі молодшими це насторожує
кілька років тому це були 18-річні
сьогодні я вже 12-літні вони існують усе
молодшими і дедалі жорстокішими
групи воюють між собою виборюючи владу у
своєму районі
у цьому парку на півдні Мадрида у квітні
був убитий ножем член домінікан Дон
плеймовірно конкуруючою бандою
мешканці тут шоковані
виникає почуття не захищеності раптом ти
опиняєшся між фронтами такого в нашому
районі ще не було а тепер подібних
випадків стає все більше вона теж була в
одній із таких банд і теж походить із
домініканської республіки Дженні Так ми
повинні її називати приєдналася до банди
у 12 років і закохалася в одного з босів
у 14 років вона завагітніла і таємно
зробила аборт
Мої батьки багато працювали приділяли
мені мало уваги ніякої ласки Та це дала
мені банда а вони сказали ми твоя сім'я
тобі нічого не бракуватиме ми тобі
допоможемо це саме те чого я тоді
потребувала
сьогодні Дженні 26 і вона вийшла з банди
які домі її підтримав пастор Альберто
Діас із центру допомоги євангельської
церкви за його оцінками у Мадриді до
таких банд належить тисячі дітей і
підлітків з часів пандемії вони стали
дуже популярними особливо завдяки
Інтернету
соціальні мережі відіграють ключову роль
у їхній популяризації
п'ята форма тік-ток інстаграма також
частково Фейсбук є справжньою місцями
їхньої популярності
там поширюються нескінченно багато
дописів які прославляють банди а також
відео
якось цей кліп
вступити в такі банди легко вийти
навпаки для більшості Майже неможливо
те саме було із Дженні
це важко адже конкуруючий банди тебе теж
знають
і вони питають Що трапилося Чому ти
більше не з'являєшся на районі просто
тому що ти багато знаєш твоя група
боїться що ти розкажеш комусь цю
інформацію тому вони стежать за тобою
поліція суворо ставиться до молодіжних
банд під час захоплення на півночі
Мадрида кілька тижнів тому вони
заарештували сімох членів домінікан
донплей Троє з них ймовірно лідери
домі також заарештовували кілька разів
Сьогодні він відвідує шкільні уроки щоб
виховувати молодь
діти втягуються в те чого не знають
спочатку їх дурять а потім у них
з'являється проблеми з окремих сім'ї
діти втрачають свою юність і скільки я
відчув це на власному досвіді Я хочу
допомогти не стільки з виходом тільки з
тим щоб вони взагалі не ставали частиною
банку
адже молодіжні банди - це як наркотик Ти
швидко стаєш від них залежним І лише
одиницям вдається вийти з них
[музика]
Недоторкана природа Можна було б
пропустити що в нас Шотландії повсюди з
її величезними болотами лісами
пасовищами однак на західному узбережжі
навколо озера лох крейніш під водою
відбувається маленька кліматична драма
тобто тут зникає все більше водоростей
рослини які не лише покращують якість
води але й зв'язують дуже багато СО2
більше ніж площі лісів на суходолі не
дивно що екологи зараз особливо дбають
про догляд за луками з водоростей
Боснія і Герцеговина хоче в Європейський
союз багато мешканців багатонаціональних
держави босніївців сервів і хорватів
знають що для цього в Україні необхідно
провести реформи та мати функціонуючу
державу зокрема у сфері управління
відходами багатьох громадах як от какані
управління не бракує але надійна
утилізацію відходів відсутня екоактивіст
сафет кубат спостерігає що іноді сміття
потрапляє на дикі звалища вздовж річок з
такою бюрократією допомагає лише одне
взятися за справу самому
вони приходять на заклик з кафе та
кубата Іноді він сам трохи дивується і з
успішності своїх дій цього разу
активістів понад 30 від семи років до 77
люди тут здебільшого організовувалися
самі
Ніхто з них не задіяних жодних установах
громадських ініціативах чи фірмах
лише громадяни будь-якого віку та всіх
етнічних груп Серби хорвати босніться та
інші
яка його стали їх
сьогодні вони працюють на берегах річки
босна яка дала назву всій країні
неймовірно красива річковий пейзаж чиста
ідилія на перший погляд Якщо ж
придивитися уважніше то на протилежному
березі у воді скупчилися старі шини
на природі все швидко обростає однак під
сходом залишається сміття надовго дуже
надовго
і дістати його важко сміття по всій
території Боснії є величезною проблемою
і це набридає все більшої кількості
людей
наші річки справді брудні
забруднені заводами які викидають усе
можливе а також нашими співвітчизниками
які викидають сміття прямо в річки
ми тут різних національностей з усієї
країни просто тут дещо відбувається і
люди прокидаються
софет руками бореться зі сміттям адже
воно скрізь А що тому що про це
недостатньо піклується влада
одна з найбільших причин чому Боснії та
герцеговині завжди так багато сміття
полягає в тому що особливо сільські
місцевості сміття вивозиться не скрізь
це по-перше
по-друге влада тобто контролюючі органи
не карають нелегальні підприємства з
утилізації відходів їм бракує
інструментів або вони не мають
необхідної інформації
тому сафет продовжує встановлювати
приховані камери вони фіксують
зловмисників
доказовий матеріал для влади
ми діємо коли нам повідомляють громадяни
где можемо
пронач іде би не виявили тих хто
незаконно викинув сміття ми намагаємося
покарати їх якомога суворіше
але так буває не завжди каже Сат його
головний важіль інтернет майже три роки
тому він заснував у Facebook групу Be
The Change тобто будь зміною рекорд
вражає наразі пройшло понад 3,5 тисячі
акцій із очищення території по всій
країні у яких взяли участь понад 20
тисяч людей
це для Боснії щось нове люди
самоорганізовуються незалежно від
кордонів та поза етнічними групами тому
що вважають що держава не справляється
коли природа і довкілля гарні то люди
можуть приїжджати сюди і відпочивати
Якщо таке під силу людям в Західній
Європі то чому б це неможливо було б
Боснії
тим часом долучаються також інші зокрема
місцеві підприємства і з утилізації
відходів вони вже давно борються з надто
малими коштами та застрілим обладнанням
завдяки пораді сафета зараз у них є
принаймні прес для сміття наступний крок
сортування сміття
результатом нашої співпраці з групою
Facebook є те що ми тепер запроваджуємо
два різних контейнери для сортування
сміття Це початок
перша ідея біла туда оскільки слід
розуміти що екологічну свідомості зараз
мало як серед громадян так і в цілому по
всій країні
потім він показує нам що має на увазі
парковки неподалік завалена сміттям
залишки після блошиного ринку Вони
прибирають її щотижня невдовзі все
повторюються
Ми повинні більше працювати над
екологічною свідомістю щоб люди краще
розумілися на екології
щоб розуміли людський бік цієї проблеми
і головне щоб усвідомили значення
догляду за довкіллям
на Боснія вони вже зробили великі Крок
уперед діти у захваті приступають до
діла
кожен шматок сміття надає відчуття
успіху
незабаром його вже ціла купа
і її забирає тут уже підключається Влада
служба з вивезення сміття
результат очищення кількох метрів
берегової лінії
Я залюбки роблю це оскільки хочу щоб
природа була чистою без сміття коли я
виходжу з дому Я хочу щоб було гарно і
зелено без сміття
[музика]
все ж таки красивіше скрізь чисто зелень
замість сміття
Я рада що ми сьогодні хоч трохи прибрали
можливо половину того що тут лежить
тож на берегах босни росте нова
екологічна свідомість
Зараз ми познайомимо вас з італійцем
Бруно феріном він володіє парком розваг
з американськими гірками колесом огляду
Та ланцюгової каруселлю все це
побудовано власним руками і Бруно
обійшовся без надмірностей без
високоякісних технологій і цифрових
ефектів натомість зелене середовище парк
стоїть посеред лісу в регіоні Венето на
півночі Італії зараз ви скажете але ж
для його роботи необхідно досить багато
особливо дорогої наразі енергії якраз ні
рульова доріжка
горбатий автомобіль
колесо смерті
[музика]
це лише деякі з 37 атракціонів парку
розваг
ip-о-під тополями
саме він збудував їх власними руками
Ти повинна тримати ноги вперед
витягнутими вперед так Саме так інакше
ти стукнешся носом об гумову стіну
бруноферіну 85 років
півстоліття тому він поставив тут свою
першу гойдалку
Я радію коли приїжджаю сюди і бачу
скільки всього Я побудував за 50 років
дуже приємно мати можливість сказати про
власне життя я здійснив усі свої мрії
Уявіть собі
його мрія почалася У 1969 році і з
ресторану Бруно закохався у цей шматочок
лісу поки дружина подавала під тополями
вино та ковбаси Бруно почав будувати
гойдалки усього він навчився сам
я закінчили ще 5 класів початкової школи
але цифри завжди є в голові
[музика]
я автоматично знаю як працює вага та
противага для моїх атракціонів
що регулювати шасі якщо Вони занадто
важкі або ж нахил неправильний
особливість парку Бруно в тому що жоден
із його атракціонів не потребує
електрики вони використовують закони
фізики та силу м'язів відвідувачів
найновіший атракціон ця Карусель
телевізійний репортаж про навчальний
центр для астронавтів НАСА підказав йому
цю ідею каже умілиць
ця Карусель працює з цими велосипедами
Якими мають керувати відвідувачі коли ти
наступаєш на педаль Карусель крутиться
чим швидше вона крутиться тим більшою
стає відцентрована сила і каркаси сидінь
рухаються від центру назад
[музика]
У той час як інші партії розваг
ризикують закритися через стіни на
енергоносії Бруно будує плани на
майбутнє навіть у похилому віці
ціни на електроенергію злетіли Ось чому
ми розглядаємо можливість встановлення
Динамо машин на кожному атракціоні щоб
генерувати енергію за рахунок руху всіх
механізмів Це мій план
ідеї яка могла б у Великому масштабі
навіть перекреслити плани світових
стратегів
Путін мабуть не зрадів у такому парку як
мій бик би так працювало все він би
більше не продавав газ Італії
до речі за десятилітню історію його
парку не трапилось жодного нещасного
випадку каже Бруно просто він усе
помічає
гей хлопче Сядь негайно
ти повинен сидіти бо це небезпечно
Ось такі вони вони просто не читають
вказівки
італійці у вас Німеччині вказівки закон
У нас вони не обов'язково найкраще якщо
я навіть не буду читати що там написано
Ось такі італійці щорічно сюди приїжджає
50 тисяч відвідувачів парк відкритий
лише у вихідні дні вхід вільний
незалежно від того багато людина чи
бідна Кожен повинен мати право на
розваги філософствує Бруно коли
відвідувачі запитують його Чому він
відповідає
коли роблю наприкінці року фінансовий
звіт і у мене залишається лише 1 євро
прибутку то я задоволений
можливо не Всі розуміють що концепцію
але мені вистачає
більшість відвідувачів парку також їдять
і п'ють у ресторані Бруно так
оплачується бізнес навіть у своїй 84
роки він ще скрізь допомагає Свобода
займатися улюбленою справою зберегла
його молодим
чудово і він повністю присвятив її
своєму парку розваг
це прекрасне життя
Залежно від настрою я вирішую що я хочу
робити сьогодні Гарно правда мої дорогі
це поезія життя
[музика]
поезія з парку розваг Це була програма
фокусі Європи компанії Deutsche Welle
Дякую вам за те що ви з нами що вам
найкращого українською мовою озвучено
центром Меді ініціатив переклад
Володимира та Олеся Швед режисер Павло
Тимченко так читали Олена потоцька Юлія
Лисенко та Олесь гоян Київ 2022 рік